y
[Música]
más de 180 personas han perdido de la
vida por las fuertes inundaciones en
cuatro países del occidente de europa
cientos de personas permanecen
desaparecidas o incomunicadas al tiempo
que rescatistas y militares continúan
las labores de limpieza la canciller
alemana angela merkel visitó la zona más
afectada por la catástrofe en su nación
regresó a haití martino y la esposa del
presidente yo en el movice tras una
semana en miami donde recibió
tratamiento por las heridas que sufrió
durante el ataque en el que el
mandatario perdió la vida portando un
chaleco antibalas la viuda fue recibida
por el primer ministro interino closer
hay alerta en tokio luego de que se
reportaran los dos primeros contagios de
atletas que residen en la villa olímpica
y que se suman al primero de un
colaborador informado ayer se trata de
tres extranjeros pertenecientes a la
misma delegación en total 13 nuevos
positivos fueron identificados este
domingo
buen día para todos bienvenidos a esta
emisión de noticias en france 24 soy
valentina torre sánchez iniciamos esta
informativo en alemania donde la
canciller angela merkel visita en estos
momentos el estado de renania palatinado
el más afectado por las inundaciones
para constatar los daños y visitar a los
sobrevivientes y es que más de 180
personas han fallecido en cuatro países
de europa 157 de las víctimas se
encontraban en alemania donde también
hay decenas de desaparecidos en varias
zonas el ejército y equipos de rescate
trabajan a contrarreloj para encontrar a
las personas de las que no se tiene
noticia y desbloquear las
infraestructuras afectadas
con el agua hasta la cintura estos
soldados tienen una difícil misión deben
abrir puertas de coches e inspeccionar
cada vehículo en busca de personas que
pudieron haberse quedado sin tiempo para
escapar antes de la llegada de la
inundación el ejército ha movilizado
todos sus recursos para reabrir esta
autovía en donde la inundación provocó
que algunos vehículos quedaran apilados
unos sobre otros los soldados han estado
sacando los uno a uno tenemos 28
vehículos aquí el agua ha comenzado a
descender pero todavía no sabemos si hay
personas dentro de los coches esperamos
que todo el mundo consiguiera salir a
tiempo en alemania las consecuencias de
las inundaciones se empeoran con las
horas en esta región la atmósfera es
sombría al final de la calle los equipos
de rescate están dando una terrible
noticia a un residente han encontrado en
el garaje el cuerpo sin vida de uno de
sus familiares
una tragedia para la familia y un trauma
para el país
en la prensa alemana se están publicando
decenas de fotos de personas
desaparecidas y para muchos se hace
insoportable hay demasiados muertos
y lo siento no puedo más
en algunas ciudades ha habido muestras
masivas de solidaridad con cientos de
donaciones recibidas en unas horas
un día también ha sido víctima de otro
desastre climático al menos 25 personas
perdieron la vida y hay numerosos
desaparecidos a causa de varios
deslizamientos en mumbai capital
económica del país las fuertes lluvias
causaron el colapso de más de una decena
de viviendas y produjeron los deslaves
los equipos de rescate buscan
sobrevivientes bajo los escombros al
tiempo que anunciaron que el número de
fallecidos podría aumentar las
autoridades meteorológicas han indicado
que se prevé que el temporal que afecta
el estado de maharashtra en el occidente
del país dure unos cuatro días más
recibimos información del colapso
alrededor de las seis de la mañana
nuestro equipo ya estaba desplegado aquí
porque el nivel del agua había aumentado
y tan pronto como recibimos la
información nuestro equipo llegó al
lugar de inmediato y comenzó la
operación de rescate
en otras noticias martín moisés esposa
del asesinado del presidente de haití
job en el moisés volvió a su país tras
estar una semana en miami donde recibió
tratamiento por las heridas que sufrió
durante el ataque en el cual su esposo
perdió la vida la vio de maurice que
bajó del avión portando un chaleco
antibalas fue recibida el sábado por el
primer ministro interino claude joseph
que está al frente del gobierno el
funeral del mandatario está programado
para el viernes
vestida de luto y aún recuperándose de
sus heridas así aterrizó de regreso en
haití martí moix la viuda del presidente
haitiano jouvenel moix tras recuperarse
en un hospital de miami su arribo se
produce días antes del funeral de su
esposo pautado para el 23 de julio en la
ciudad de cap-haitien
la primera dama martín hoy se acaba de
llegar a haití en el marco de los
preparativos de las honras fúnebres
nacionales del presidente joven el mois
fue recibida en el aeropuerto
internacional por el primer ministro
cloud josep job en el mois aún no está
en la tumba pero su ausencia repentina
ha desatado una lucha por llenar un
vacío de poder sumiendo al país en una
inestabilidad política aún mayor
claude joseph ha liderado haití con el
respaldo de la policía y el ejército a
pesar de que maurice lo había
reemplazado por ariel henry por decreto
dos días antes de su muerte el
presidente del senado joseph lambert se
encuentra entre los que se disputan el
poder el actual premier interino insiste
que él debe gobernar sin embargo ha
pedido apoyo para resolver la crisis del
país
ariel si soy el primer ministro de facto
ariel enrique es el primer ministro
designado pero nunca fue nombrado joseph
lambert es senador es presidente del
senado pero no es presidente de la
asamblea nacional porque la cámara de
diputados no existe así que nosotros
tres y los otros sectores tenemos que
unirnos para encontrar una solución
no obstante en un revés para claude
joseph el llamado core grupo integrado
por embajadores y representantes de la
oea y naciones unidas dio un espaldarazo
a ariel henry para la tarea de formar
gobierno el grupo hizo un llamado a que
se realicen elecciones legislativas y
presidenciales justas y libres cuanto
antes la oposición haitiana duda que
pueda llevarse a cabo en menos de un año
dada la crisis que atraviesa el país el
papá francisco llamó al diálogo y la
solidaridad con el pueblo cubano durante
el rezo del ángelus este domingo el
pontífice expresó su preocupación señaló
que la isla vive momentos difíciles y
resaltó la necesidad de que haya una
sociedad más justa y fraterna las
palabras se producen aún
semana de las históricas protestas
antigubernamentales que fueron
reprimidas por el gobierno de miguel
díaz canel y en las que se produjeron
detenciones y choques violentos
el cob el 19 vuelve a poner en jaque los
juegos olímpicos de tokio se confirmaron
los dos primeros positivos de atletas
que se encuentran alojados en la villa
olímpica
los organizadores no indicaron de dónde
vienen los positivos pero anunciaron que
toda la delegación fue puesta en
cuarentena los casos hacen parte de un
total de 10 reportados este domingo
incluyen un tercer deportista que no
residía dentro de la villa a su vez el
equipo de fútbol de sudáfrica reportó
tres contagios entre su selección
incluso tomando todas las medidas en su
totalidad habrá algunos casos positivos
bajo la situación del coronavirus que
abarca a todo el mundo por lo que es
inevitable que haya casos lo importante
es que cuando surjan tales casos
aislarlos adecuadamente y
sistemáticamente para que no haya más
transmisiones es la variante delta del
hobbit 19 continúa siendo un tema de
preocupación para el mundo según la
organización mundial de la salud se ha
convertido en dominante en varios países
mientras los expertos advierten que
podría desencadenar una posible quinta
ola de contagios la amenaza que
representa la variante ha llevado a
varios gobiernos a acelerar las campañas
de vacunación y a re imponer
veamos el informe de reaccionaba espí
negro
la propagación de la variante delta no
se detiene la creciente amenaza del
virus ha enfocado a la preocupación en
los no vacunados principalmente los
jóvenes del está es más peligrosa y
doblemente contagiosa según expertos y
ha despertado la alerta en varios países
llevando algunos a retomar restricciones
la propagación de delta ha estado
acompañada de un aumento de las muertes
en eeuu principalmente entre las
personas inoculadas como advierten las
autoridades de washington hay un mensaje
claro que está llegando esto se está
convirtiendo en una pandemia de los no
vacunados y andrew schneider we are sing
estamos viendo brotes de casos en partes
del país que tienen una baja cobertura
de vacunación porque las personas no
vacunadas están en riesgo y las
comunidades que están totalmente
vacunadas están generalmente greenway la
preocupación también está en europa que
puso en alerta a los estados tras un
alza en las cifras de contagios los
líderes llamaron a sus ciudadanos a
vacunarse a medida que se re imponen
algunas restricciones como el toque de
queda nocturno en varias poblaciones de
españa y francia- o pruebas pcr para
viajeros internacionales de 24 horas de
antelación como lo ha pedido el país
galo a partir de este domingo según
advirtió la organización mundial de la
salud
aún quedan millones de personas sin
vacunar en la región de europa siendo
los jóvenes del grupo más amenazado en
américa latina' la variante se encuentra
en 14 países y supone un nuevo desafío
para los frágiles sistemas sanitarios
se espera que en agosto en países como
méjico al menos del 90% de los contagios
sean por la variante
así llegamos al final de este
informativo ustedes gracias por su
sintonía los invitamos a visitar nuestra
web france24 puntocom para ampliar estas
y otras noticias volvemos en unos
momentos
[Música]